well the threat of new violence one year
after deadly clashes in Charlottesville
Virginia did not become reality
yesterday 61% of Americans in a CBS News
poll say racial tensions have increased
in the past year there were tense
moments in Washington where huge crowds
turned out to oppose a white supremacist
rally on the Charlottesville anniversary
Kris Van Cleave is at Lafayette Park
near the White House on the scene of the
protest Kris good morning
well good morning we saw the white
supremacist group unite the right
ushered out of here in a hurry yesterday
as police were engaged in a tense
standoff with a group of counter
protesters a confrontation in the name
of the First Amendment
crowds jeered as a small group of white
supremacists arrived in the nation's
capitol under heavy police protection
they spoke in front of a virtually
non-existent crowd and were cut short by
weather
uh sure doubt by police and vans and
away from an angry crowd of counter
protesters
[Applause]
the counter protests far outnumbered
unite the right Sunday but some in the
crowd baited police as the day wore on
what happened when unite the right
demonstrators came out of Lafayette
Square a huge crowd of counter
demonstrators has gathered here some are
throwing eggs some are throwing bottles
in the direction of the police large
police presence has masked here still
the counter protests were largely
peaceful focusing on a message of
resisting racism today I hope that we
out sign all of their hate right why
can't me just shift the narrative of
last year when it was so traumatizing
the 10th day marked the one-year
anniversary of the violent white
supremacist rally that turned deadly in
Charlottesville Virginia a year after
drawing outrage from his reaction the
president chose to preempt the
controversy tweeting Saturday I condemn
all types of racism and acts of violence
the president has not spoken further
about the incident yesterday now the
police DC police say there were no
reports of any injuries and made only
one arrest we know of one other arrest
made by police in Virginia related to
this incident that really underscores
just how peaceful the vast majority of
the demonstrators out here were Alex
Chris thanks